on the hill tonight for the padres to
nelson lumet
the 28 year old making his 10th start so
one out one on and here is
jack peterson swing and a foul tip and
that is held on to for strike three
first strikeout for denelson lament two
down and max muncie coming up machado
ducks back into short right now
and a swing and a miss lameet with
back-to-back strikeouts
it started for clayton kershaw this year
198 earned run average
fourth in the national league tatis out
of 2-2
tatis swings and misses at a good slider
good depth to it for kershaw to get a
strikeout
no score in the first inning as austin
nola comes to bat for san diego
a check swing tapper back to kershaw a
low throw muncie has time to grab it and
step in the bag to complete a one two
three first
one now one on edwin rios coming up pay
off pitch
runner goes pitches high throw down and
it won't matter it is
a strike him out throw him out i thought
the pitch was high but it was called a
strike
we'll get a look at it but nobody in the
ballpark was entirely sure but he
thought it was high
a late call from homeland umpire ripping
her and that's
just slaps the tag on as bellinger just
cruising in thinking it's ball four
and now second and third with one gone
and boy seeger stands in
0-1 to seeger is raked on the ground his
second profar will throw to first to get
him but the dodgers have the game's
first run
barnes into score on a seeger ground out
and it's one nothing
first shaw so far so good 31 pitches 22
for strikes
got him swinging with the slider here's
trend grisham with one on and one out
fastball to the inside corner locks him
up strike three
two out tatis jr strikes him out again
nelson lamette back to the hill having
thrown 48 pitches
through the first three he needs a quick
one right here lead rona ron and chris
taylor
swing and a miss got him to go after the
slider and now six strikeouts for
denelson
and edwin rios swinging a miss and rio
strikes out onto the fifth gavin lux
down the stretch and that is strike
three eight strikeouts for
nelson lamet one down in the fifth that
strikes out and lumet gets him that's
nine strikeouts for lametta one two
three fifth
trent crusher leading it off here in the
sixth inning
in the air to deep right field for
christian it's gone
and the padres tie it one to one one
swing of the battle get it done
home run number nine of the year for
grisham has tied this game off clayton
kershaw
oh we got some chirping going on trent
grisham
crushed this baseball and he watched it
he was in the batter's box when that
ball was struck there was no doubt about
it
i'd say it's on clayton kershaw to the
bottom of the seventh inning in a 1-1
game
what a pitcher's duel this has been
between kershawn lament
the go-ahead run is the board to open
the seventh inning for san diego
one on one out here's profar on the
ground and through a vacated right side
into right field myers will throw the
brakes on as he got to seconds but he
sit for pro farm first and second one
down
dave roberts out to try and take it from
kershaw with jorge o'neil do up clayton
tried to talk him out of it but
to no avail dave roberts gives it to
pedro baez
onya sends it to left field down the
line peterson headed over is not going
to get there
coming around from second is myers he'll
score and the padres take a 2-1
lead jorge run
charge to kershaw and it's garcia pinch
hitting
garcia hits on the ground to first
muncie is going to
come home with it and safe at the plate
getting in front third is profile
he eludes the tag
right there that's when profar made the
decision to commit home
the nice slide away got the back end of
home plate
the race is on and he most definitely
wins it right there
and so it's first and second still just
one out and here is christian
on the ground to first base muncie will
go to second
and throw it into left field so coming
around to zhonya
he will score on the errant throw and
the padres take a 4-1 lead
pitching change again for la they'll
move on to their third arm of the ninth
base is loaded now with one out
on the ground base hit into right field
from third base comes garcia
he will score as betz gets it back in
and the padres take a 5-1 lead
manny machado with an opposite field rbi
single
austin nola's over three nola chops one
towards third base rios
[Applause]
in from third is grisham and the padres
add another run well myers
leads it off here in the eighth myers
drives this to deep right center field
mookie betts going back myers has left
the building
home run to right field for will myers
his 13th of the year and the padres take
a definitive
7-1 lead don you mentioned it earlier
we've talked about will myers and the
way he was swinging the bat in spring
training in peoria and that was classic
will myers
right then and there your pitcher is
pierce johnson the third of the night
for san diego
two down taylor at second and here's
edwin rios
in the air to left field sending pro
fire back he will
get there and the padres win the padres
with a
7-2 victory over the los angeles dodgers
in game one of the series